thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Tim is in Grand
Rapids Michigan hey Tim how are you
that's a bad day of yourself better than
I deserve what's up um I have been
really divorced and through that I was
able to become debt-free through your
program cool with the one exception of I
screwed up
prior to listening to you and co-signed
a student loan for my second son mm-hmm
who has now not paid the student loan
and I just found out from Wells Fargo
that they have written it off and I owe
fifty three thousand six hundred and
forty two dot forty eight cents and I
don't know the best way to do it well is
it a federally insured student loan I
believe so
now it's a Sallie Mae loan then okay all
right huh well that the problem is when
you co-sign something it means also sign
and in if the person that is the primary
doesn't pay you're liable and so you're
100% liable for this is the problem and
I assume he's going to do nothing that's
the plan for him right now I don't
believe you can okay and what do you
make of your sixty thousand okay and I'm
guessing you don't have fifty three
grand laying around right I do not you
know they offered a settlement of thirty
four thousand 861 eleven really no I
don't have that sitting around left I
got out of a retirement phone real early
given half of that alight to my wife
ex-wife well there's uh something wrong
because you're not going to get a
settlement offer that low on a Sallie
Mae government insured loan this is not
a Sallie Mae loan okay it must be a
Wells Fargo that's all I know
student loan yeah it must be a private
student loan that what kind of school
did he go - you went to uh it was Full
Sail University on the island of Florida
or computer-animated yeah he went for
computer um Healing guess he didn't get
a Sallie Mae loan is that school still
open yeah
okay huh do you have the ability to
borrow it anywhere else because I mean
you're getting assume you're getting a
deep discount here get rid of this thing
and you know if you could put together
even 25 grand at all from that I mean
you own a home you can get a second
mortgage on that's what I sold and got
out of debt so I rent right now and with
this on my now on my credit I'd have to
find a friend or family yeah don't do
that no no no I'm if anyone okay how
much is in the 401k um I think I've got
about eighty thousand left now I'm just
here's the problem you pull money on
that 401k you're in a 25% tax bracket
you're going to get hit with 25% plus
10% penalty 35% and they're not
discounting it that far are the
discounting it about that far actually
but so what I would do is one of two
things first thing I'd probably do is
just tell them I can't pay you anything
okay
it's bad credit it's bad on your credit
it's just sitting there and then I would
get about the business of piling up cash
as fast as you can pile it up because if
you waive 20 or $25,000 cash in front of
their nose they're probably going to
take it but it's going to take it's
going to take you like you know a year
of beans and rice to put that together
right right and that'll get rid of the
loan completely it will be completely
gone at that point and for your son and
for you so you know that that would be a
way to do it but it does it's not going
to make math mathematical sense to cash
up the 401k to do this okay so the only
thing I hear is the only place I hear
for you to make money as an income and
you know what how much does your son
make a year
um he's trying to be self-employed I
think that's the biggest issue
I'm gathered from him is he's got enough
to pay his rent and pay is electric and
food so he's single he's single how old
is he
I 27 and and I have a big discussion on
getting his blood out and working yeah
you know - because he's gonna he's gonna
pay me back
he's gonna help me get this thing taken
care of exactly I think you pile up as
much cash between the two of you as
quickly as you can and again I'm
thinking if you waive 50 cents on the
dollar you know 20 $25,000 under their
nose they're going to take it because
I'm thinking they they don't figure
they're going to get money they figure
this down and you're just settling
basically this is regardless of what it
what kind of a loan it was originally
it's basically a large unsecured
personal loan that the two of you have
signed and that's the way Wells Fargo is
looking at it and so they're running the
numbers going this twenty-seven-year-old
the self-employed is not going to pay us
this recently divorced guy making 60
grand is not going to pay us we're up a
creek that's what their numbers are
telling them okay and before I do
anything again get everything in writing
that they agree to it correct
always always FN so but I'm going to
make them some kind of a cash offer that
I throw up you know because I've thrown
some money in a pile and able to do that
the next year so between you and your
son and the two of you lock arms and say
okay we but we have a mutual problem
here that we're going to mutually jump
on and solve and that's how I would do
it hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Music]